Until now we've been working
on a single machine.
It's time to start thinking about
scaling up and scaling out.
So let's bring our
expert Adrian back in.
>> Hi there.
>> Hey, Adrian, thanks for coming back.
What role do you see containers
playing in the future of
application development and deployment?
Well if you look at the history of
having large systems in the data center.
Bare metal machines,
typically you'd buy them,
you'd depreciate them over three years.
They'd sit at the same IP address.
They get installed once and
used over and over again, and
you can think of those machines as pets.
What we really want
to do is have cattle.
Right.
So if you lose some
you know one cow out of a dairy
hood you still got milk, right.
You can get another cow.
That's that kind of model,
rather than having some machine that's
very specific and
if one knows its name and
if they have anything goes wrong
with it everyone gets very unhappy.
So that transition from sort of
these very specific machines to
more sort of fleets or
herds of machines is
something that happened typically when,
you know, you can do it with the VMs.
But VMs take out as, you know,
they basically usually you get
them by the hour and they last for
a few weeks and you know they
have a much shorter life cycle.
But when we go to
containers became efficient
enough that you could actually
get a machine in seconds and
you could run it for minutes and that
was a perfectly reasonable thing to do.
So, you can create an entire
test environment from scratch,
run it until when and run all your
tests, shut it down again and
you can have lots of those
running in parallel.
So now you've got machines,
some of them you barely know they exist,
they come and go very, very quickly.
And finally, sort of,
if you take it right to the limit,
you could create a container just to run
a single request and shut it down again.
And that's something that's starting
to be called serverless computing,
and there's a few frameworks for
doing that.
But that's sort of the leading edge
of what's happening right now.
>> So when it comes to writing
containerized apps other than make it
smaller, what are problems
that no one's talking about?
>> So one of the problems is
that people get into is if
they keep their old organization and
the old practices.
So if you've got a micro service or
an application you are building and
the way you used to build your
monolith was you had teams spread
all around the world that
contributed code into the system and
you spent, you know,
weeks of putting everything together.
So when we created software
it sort of followed the form.
That form,
this is sometimes called Conway's law
which says that the structure
of an organization
guides the kind of structure
of the code they produce.
So what I'm really saying is that
you can't build micro services with
a waterfall organization.
>> So people might lose some of the
benefits of the microservices pattern
with organizational issues.
What about technical
issues like monitoring,
logging what are problems with those?
>> And so you need much more automation.
That's a lot more moving parts,you need
systems that dynamically discover what
to be monitored and track them.
So, that's the kind of
characteristic you're looking for.
>> That sounds like a lot goes
into it is this something
developers are programming themselves?
We're looking back five years when
Netflix first started doing this.
One of the things we had was that
because we were early we had to invent
a lot of stuff ourselves.
And there was just, we went and
read papers and we built things, right.
And what the situation now is that
there's really too many things to
choose from and you spend more time
trying to figure out which GitHub
lipo has something useful in it,
which open source project,s and
which the SAS vendor is
trying to sell you something.
So, there's just too many
choices right now, and
those choices are changing
really rapidly.
>> So, it sounds like infrastructure
is something really important,
maybe not to code yourself
because there's so much, so
find something that works, use it for
now change or readjust as you go.
>> Yeah, there's no need to build it
yourself now, and there's too many good
options out there, too many things
you can just get hold of and use.
There're cloud based services.
There's On Premise.
There's things you can download for
free.
So something that could be an 80s has a
lot of functionality you can just go use
it and you don't have to go try and
build all that yourself.
So they're building higher and
higher level services on top of
lots of the detailed engineering what
goes into building these frameworks and
then you can build on top of them.
>> Okay thank you so much for
coming in and talking about this.
>> Thanks very much.
>> After talking with Adrian,
one of the industry's leading
experts on this subject,
it turns out that infrastructure is just
as important as the application itself.
This course is going to
cover the theory and
implementation of managing
that infrastructure.
So in this course we're going to move
past theory and show you how to do it,
and we'll be using Kubernetes for that.